hello I'm Katalin and zkp and I am
junior studying computer science and
engineering
my project is camera system for indoor
localization and human identification
smart home technology is becoming more
and more popular since its give people
the power to control the device in their
home to detect indoor accidents and to
do health analysis to support this
application with multi-user
many research try to differentiate users
in the system but they it is difficult
for them to achieve both high accuracy
and comfort at the same time this system
eat her required user to carry an extra
D white with trans trade of the convoy
or use the camera with very detailed
vision recognition such as face which
can be wearing were blurry in the low
resolution cameras or wearing low speed
camera in most of alien system in order
to achieve both comfort and accuracy we
continue to use camera system and you
overcome the low resolution issue by
using the shirt color as a temporary
identity of user my project start with
using open post to track human and then
get their joints then we use their
joints such as shoulder and elbow to
extract the shirt as you can see in here
that we draw the polygon then we find
all possible identification of people
across multiple camera then we compute
errors for each match shirt to be able
to obtain the best prediction at the end
we are able to get around 93% average
accuracy with this main improvement we
also acknowledge that we use shirt as
term identity this will allow us to
achieve real time speed but in the
future we will intricate this system
with all her high accuracy but maybe
slower and use heavy way computation
like machine learning to fill in the gap
between the short transition when people
no longer wear the same shirt during the
day